five who says she isn't strongest back
oh no went for the snake edge that gets
the second it goes for it
always lacombe going to pay for this the
second ratio if you don't see this very
often drops the combo oh that was sick
that was sick i will take that one a
comeback mob down but not out for
oh look at the dashing now from the
coming feeling confident
you're dashing again oh what the lowest
feeling is actually
oh my goodness look at me this guy is
great now
[Music]
why is everyone staying down against
noctis today the wolves blackness could
be the round
rage are i
this could kill
yeah it's going to be very close because
axe has a lot of health
yeah no the magic pixel
key charge set oh
wow
two a little bit to kind of find his
footing here in this match
unless
[Music]
oh ten seconds okay running rage rap
plus two billion but look at the time
down three
no way
is that it what what what what
oh my goodness
one the rage watch the rage one launch
does it here for bumblebee
that's it that's the that's the game
right it's gotta be dead i it has to be
it has to be
are we
what oh god what's going to happen oh no
pauline's last chance he jumped set up
incident what chip damage
that was chip damage
[Music]
[Music]
you